DAN ROAM: Thank you.
[? Stephane's ?] right.
So this is exciting for me,
because this is actually
the third time I've had
a chance to come and do
an Authors at Google Talk.
So I want to thank all
of you for inviting
me back a third time.
Today, what I want
to talk to you about
is a new book that I wrote.
It just came out a
couple of months ago.
And it's very exciting,
because I just
got a note from Amazon the other
day that said that they've just
voted this as one of
the top 20 business
books of the year,
which is very exciting.
The book is called
"Show and Tell."
Yes?
Isn't that awesome?
The book is called
"Show and Tell--
How Everybody Can Make
Extraordinary Presentations."
And this is a very
meta kind of a talk,
because you're going
to see that I'm
making a presentation
about making presentations.
And so I just thought
the best way to start
is to give you a story
about presentations,
or a story about
public speaking.
And in this story, we're
going to have four characters.
So the first character
is this guy right here.
You they recognize his face.
Not many people do.
But you might
recognize his name.
This is Michael Bay.
Now, Michael Bay, of course, is
Hollywood's loudest director.
This is the guy who created
all the "Transformers" movies
and "Pearl Harbor"
and is generally
acknowledged as the best
director of explosions ever.
So Michael Bay-- here we
have this super-experienced
entertainment professional.
And the story I wanted to share
about him was, late last year,
he was supposed to give a
presentation at the Consumer
Electronics Show in Las Vegas.
He was supposed to
go on stage and give
to talk about a Samsung product.
And I don't know how many
of you may have seen this,
but it is disaster.
It's horrible to
watch what happens.
Michael Bay goes on stage,
and within about 15 seconds,
the teleprompter breaks,
and he can't continue.
He just totally freaks out on
stage, panics, stumbles around,
and it's horrible.
It's just cringe-inducing
to watch this on YouTube.
And finally, he says, I'm
story, and leaves the stage
after about 20 seconds.
It's terrible.
So that's Michael Bay.
So character number two in our
story about public speaking
is this guy, John Travolta,
clearly also a very experienced
entertainment professional.
Did anybody watch the
Academy Awards last year?
So John Travolta is supposed to
introduce Idina Menzel, who's
going to go up and
sing to "Let It Go."
And John Travolta
of all people, who's
had a life in
entertaining, gets on stage
and totally mumbles
the name, forgets
what he's supposed
to say, and says,
and now I'm going to introduce
the amazing megastar, Adele
Dazeem.
Who the hell is Adele Dazeem?
This person doesn't exist.
OK, and character number
three is the real Adele,
who we all know.
So real Adele, incredible
entertainer, of course,
won six Grammy awards
a year and a half ago.
But here's the question.
Has anybody heard
anything from Adele
in the last year and a half?
The most amazing breakout
artist of two years ago is gone.
Where is Adele?
Well, she has gone on
record-- it's interesting,
because there's different rumors
she's working on a new album.
No, she's not.
It's all denied by her agents.
Adele has decided to take
a five-year hiatus off
of performing because she said
that the act of going on stage
is too stressful for her.
Performing is too stressful.
Wow.
This is interesting.
And now here's a fourth
guy, doesn't really
belong with the rest of these.
Anyone know who this is?
This is Warren Buffett,
probably best known
as the second
wealthiest man on Earth.
And Warren, interesting, not
an entertainment professional,
not a great entertainer
by any stretch.
But Warren is different from
the rest of these people,
because Warren
Buffett, when he was
a kid-- this is in his
biography-- decided
early on that he wanted
to be a business guy.
And he realized that, in order
to be successful in business,
he was going to have to
get over his greatest fear.
And his greatest fear
was public speaking.
He was terrorized.
He hated doing it.
But Warren knew that if he
was going to be successful,
he was going to have to be
able to figure out a way
to communicate his
ideas to other people.
So he approached public
speaking as a science.
And he said, how do I go
about doing this well?
How do I get over my
worries and my anxieties?
Took a lot of training,
did a lot of practice.
And here's the thing
that he understood
that the others do not.
All these entertainment
professionals
can't handle it when
they get on stage live.
And here we have
Mr. Business Geek,
who's the only one
who can, because he
understood something.
Presenting is as much
science as it is art.
And above all, it
takes practice.
These other folks all mess up
because they say, oh, I'm cool.
I'm charismatic.
I'll just go up on
stage and I'll wing it.
That is a guarantee for failure
when we're going to present.
So let's talk a little bit.
Why does this matter to us?
Because I know,
I know, at Google
that it is important for you,
even though your day job may
involve code or design or
technology or security.
I also know that it is
expected at some point
that each one of you is going to
have to explain to other people
what you do.
We all have to get up
on stage at some point.
In fact, I have become
convinced that there
is nothing that is more
important for our professional
success-- and in many cases, our
personal success-- than being
able to get up in front of other
people and share our ideas.
But here are-- OK, Google
folks-- here are the data.
In the most recent study,
74% percent of Americans
would rather die
than give a speech.
Wow.
That's kind of bad.
That's a global epidemic.
3/4 of all people
would rather die.
We're less afraid of dying than
we are of getting up on stage.
So I want to let you
in on a little secret.
It's actually fun to
present if we follow
a couple of very,
very simple rules.
The fear is real.
We'll talk about it a
little bit later on.
It's real, but it's
there for a good reason.
The fear becomes
a problem when it
gets so big that it
gets too crazy for us.
But all the fear is
there to tell us,
you're going to do
something stressful.
You got to perform.
If what we can do is
take that fear and say,
hey, fear, I've seen you before.
I know where you're coming from.
I know your job to me is just to
make sure that I do a good job.
We let the fear come in
and go right back out,
and we use the energy
of it passing through
to help us do a good job.
And so what I want
to share with you
is that when we give
a presentation-- it
could be anything.
It could be something that we're
just sharing with our team,
or it could be a big
formal presentation
with a cast of thousands.
It doesn't matter.
The basic idea is
always the same.
And it's kind of like
we are going on a trip.
And here we are.
This is us down here.
And here is our idea,
the thing that we
want to share in
our presentation.
And usually what happens
is we take that thing
and we show it to people.
We say, this is my thing, this
is my idea, and here it is.
And usually what happens is it's
not a very exciting engagement.
It usually lies kind
of flat like this.
And there we are sort
of showing our thing,
and some people
are falling asleep,
and some people are
checking their Android,
totally checked out.
Well, you know what?
I don't think we
should do that anymore.
In fact, I think if there's
ever an opportunity for us
to give a presentation
about anything that
has the likelihood of just lying
flat, we shouldn't give it.
We should forget all about.
Because, from now on, I think
it's really critical that we
make every presentation
we give, no matter
how low-key or
seemingly unimportant--
we want to bend that lineup and
make every single presentation
we give extraordinary.
If it's not, why are
we giving it at all?
And what's the difference
between that flat line
and that extraordinary line?
It's a very, very simple thing.
What is the difference
between this and this?
A presentation it is
extraordinary-- it's
very simple.
It's one that changes people.
And the change doesn't
need to be enormous.
It could be a very small change.
Or it could be
really, really huge.
But what we want
to understand is
that a presentation's
amazing, both for the audience
and for us presenting it, when,
at some point during that 20
minutes, 40 minutes, two
hours, whatever it is,
somebody has a little
bit of a change.
And that's what we
want to aim for.
And in order to make that
happen, it's really simple.
There are only three rules.
Three really basic
rules for making
an extraordinary presentation.
And here they are.
Rule number one, tell the truth.
Wow.
If we lead it with
the truth, the hearts
of the people we're
talking with will follow.
Rule number two, tell
that truth with a story.
If we lead with a story,
understanding will follow.
And rule number three, tell
that story with pictures.
Because if we lead with the
eye, the mind will follow.
Tell the truth, tell
it with a story,
and tell that story
with pictures.
And if we do that,
every presentation
is going to be pretty amazing.
We're going to go
through all three rules.
And I want to start weirdly
with rule number three.
I want to start with
the rule that says
we tell our story with
pictures, because I want
to share with you
initially some pictures.
And we are actually going
to take a little test.
It's a very simple test.
I don't anyone to stress out.
There's no passing or
failing in this test.
All that's going
to happen is I am
going to show you
30 random images.
And I know they're
random, because all I did
was go on Google Images
and download the first 30
images that I saw.
They're just 30 random images.
I'm going to show them to you.
We're going to look at them.
The thing is, I
don't want you to try
to memorize them or maybe
write down what they are.
You won't have time.
I just want you to look
at them, because we're
going to go through each one.
I'm going to give you about
a quarter of a second.
We're just going to
go through really,
really fast looking
at these images.
So is everybody ready to
look at some pictures?
All right.
Up at the screen, we take
a breath, and here we go.
OK.
Can anybody tell us all 30
of those pictures in order?
What did we just look at?
Of course we can't.
All right, so I want to
forget about that for moment.
Remember there were three rules.
I want to go to rule number one.
Let's talk about rule number
one for a little well.
Let's talk about this
idea of telling the truth.
And my intention here is not
to go all Boy Scout on you
and say, oh, it's all
about telling the truth.
Here's the truth.
A presentation looks like it's
about information sharing.
That's what we think a
presentation is about,
and that is partially true.
But in order for
information to be shared,
something else has
to happen first.
What a presentation is
really about is about trust.
It is about me trying
to get you to trust me,
and me trying to get me
to be trustworthy to do,
and me trusting you back.
The real idea is this.
In order for there to be
any information exchange--
if you don't trust me, if you
think I'm not very trustworthy,
nothing good is going to happen.
Here's kind of an interesting
part about this truth aspect.
There is no faster
way to establish
trust between ourselves than
for me to tell you the truth.
We all have a kind
of a sixth sense.
We know when someone
is BS-ing us.
So the converse of this rule
is also true, that says this.
There is no faster way to lose
our audience than to BS them.
We can do it for a little while.
But after a little bit
longer, people start to say,
I don't think this
is really right.
Now, OK, that's all fine.
Tell the truth.
But the tricky thing is
there is more than one truth.
There are three truths.
They all exist all the time.
One of those truths is
the truth of the data.
This is what the facts tell us.
These are the things
that we can measure.
These are the pieces
of information
that we can collect.
These are the facts, and
there is truth in them.
They are true.
There's a second truth,
though, isn't there?
Which is the truth of, what do I
think about all of those facts?
The truth that's in my head.
And then there's a
third truth, which
is the truth that's in my heart.
What do I really believe
about all of these things?
And what's
interesting, of course,
is that very often these three
truths are not in alignment.
They are not the same.
I know we all have something
that we believe we know it
in our heart to be true that the
data do not support or perhaps
for which there are no data.
What's interesting
about this, though,
is that these truths are
all true all of the time.
They all exist all of the time.
And I wanted to give you
a little example right
here about these truths.
So what do we have here?
I have a glass of water.
Now, I can give you some facts
about this glass of water.
And thank you,
[? Stephane ?], for providing
this excellent prop.
I can tell you that there are
about 4 cubic inches of H2O
in this glass,
and I can tell you
that there are 4 cubic
inches of oxygen and hydrogen
in this glass.
And those are the facts.
That's great data.
I can also say, what
do I think about that?
Well, I know that metaphorically
a half-full, full-half empty
glass is a sign of something.
I know that many people think
that a half-full glass is
a sign of optimism,
but half-empty glass
is a sign of pessimism.
So those are the things I
think about, those numbers.
And then there's what I believe.
I believe that this
glass is half full,
and nothing anybody ever says
to me is going to change that.
Those three truths are all
real and they all exist.
And guess what's interesting
about those three truths,
is it they are not
always the same.
The way we perceive those
truths is very, very different.
I like to represent it as
this kind of a pyramid.
We have endless amounts
of factual truths.
I mean, you're Google,
for goodness' sake.
You collect more data
truths than anybody.
We have more facts.
The thing about
those data truths,
though, those fact
truths, is that they're
very easy to change.
All that needs to happen is I
need to get a new data point.
Today this might be a
fact, and tomorrow that
might be a new fact.
And that's fine.
It's very easy to change
the truth of fact.
The next truth that
sits on top of that
that's a little bit harder
to change-- it's not the data
itself, but what do
I think about it?
What do I actually think
is the way the world is?
Very difficult to change.
I mean, if I think
things or something,
it's going to take me a long
time to change the way I think.
But the one that sits on the
top, the most difficult one
of all to change, is the truth
of the heart-- the truths,
the things that I believe.
I don't care about
the damn data.
I know this to be true.
To change someone's beliefs
is extraordinarily difficult.
But that is the truth
that really lasts.
That is the change
that really matters.
Point here, when we want to
change someone-- ourselves
and our audience through
giving a presentation--
we want to keep in mind
that we've got these three
things that we're going
to be working through.
How do we present these in a way
that makes sense to someone so
that the level of
change takes place?
Well, that brings us to
rule number two, which
was telling a story.
Why do we tell stories?
Stories are the
expression of something
we're going to call a storyline.
Why are stories important?
Well, because everything in
the world is complicated.
Life is complicated.
Problems are complicated.
The truth is very complicated.
And when something
is complicated,
when something is complex,
it's almost impossible for us
to figure out a
way to digest it.
We don't want to.
We just reject it.
So what a storyline does is
it takes that complexity,
and it forces it
into a line to make
that complexity tolerable
enough for us to touch into it
and try to experience
it long enough
to try to make some
sense out of it.
That's what a story does.
It takes that
complexity and forces it
into a line long enough for it
to began to make sense to us.
That's all a story does.
Which tells us that any
story, any presentation that's
based on a story,
any presentation
is going to be built
on a storyline.
And that storyline
is always clear.
There is a beginning,
there is an end,
and there is
something that happens
in between the two of them.
The storyline is not endless,
the storyline is not confusing,
and the storyline is not random.
Whenever we're going to present
anything-- it doesn't matter
whether it's a truth
of fact, it doesn't
matter if it's a
truth of the head,
or it doesn't matter if
it's a truth of the heart.
When we're going to
present anything,
we have to present it
in the form of a story,
because that's the only
way understanding's
going to come out of it.
Because stories do two things.
Certainly, they move us along
from a beginning to an ending.
They have to do that.
Come with me as I tell you about
public speaking or something.
But they have to do a
second thing as well.
It's not enough, as we know,
for the store to just lie there.
The story also has
to me move us up.
It has to change what you know
or what we understand or one
of those truths.
Otherwise, the story
has been ineffective.
We talk about storylines.
There are only four.
There are only four
storylines in the world.
Anytime give a
presentation, it is
going to be based on one
of these four storylines.
There are no more.
There are only these four.
And what I want to
do is map them out.
How many people in here have
a piece of paper and a pen,
actually have a piece
of paper and a pen?
Because here's an
interesting aspect also
about making a presentation.
On a side note,
I've already been
talking for about 15 minutes.
And at this point, no
matter how charismatic I am,
no matter how
compelling my story is,
the human brain's going
to begin to check out.
It doesn't matter.
I could be singing and dancing.
It's just going to happen.
So one of the things that's
advisable at about this point
in a presentation is give
the audience something to do.
And give them something to
do that parallels what you're
presenting about is often
a really nice little magic
trick to re-engage
the brain again.
So what we're going to
do is, rather than me
telling you there are four
storylines and here they are,
we are going to
make them together.
So the way that we're
going to do this is I'd
like you to take
your sheet of paper.
I'm going to fake
it with this-- I'll
use a horizontal Post-it note.
I want you to imagine that
this is your sheet of paper.
And hold it
horizontally like this.
And what I want you to
do is fold it in half.
Stephan, you're not
folding your paper.
All right.
Did everybody do that?
Anybody need any help?
OK, now what I want
you to do is we're
going to fold one more time.
I want you to fold it down
into quarters like that.
All right.
And now comes the big reveal.
I want you to open it up and
admire this lovely handiwork it
you've done.
We've just created a perfect
four-quadrant little chart.
And now we're going to draw,
for those of you who have a pen.
The rest of you will have
to use your fingernail.
We're going to draw.
And what we're going to
draw, one in each quadrant,
are the four storylines.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is we're going to
write some words.
So what I'd like you to
do in quadrant number
one right here is I'd like
you to write "report."
In quadrant number
two, I'd like you
to write "explanation."
"Explanation."
In quadrant number three, I'd
like you to write "pitch."
And in quadrant number four,
I'd like you to write "drama."
These are the names
of the four storylines
that define everything.
Let's look at what they
actually look like, though.
Because we know every storyline,
again, it starts at a point,
and it moves along and
takes us somewhere else.
So the report looks like this.
I'd like you to
draw a little dot.
We start here.
And then draw flat line, and
make it look a little bit
like an EEG, just little bursts
of information come along.
But for the most part,
that report just lies flat.
That's what a report does.
I'm giving you some facts.
Here's a fact.
I'm giving you some more facts.
I'm giving you another fact.
And then we're done.
Thank you.
Goodbye.
All right.
An explanation is a
little bit different.
It starts down here.
And I give you some information.
And then we take a
step up together.
And then we move along,
and we take another step.
And we take another step,
and we take another step
until we're at the end.
Now, what's different about
this than the report is
we can see that, rather than
just the line of facts, what
we're actually doing
is building something.
Each fact or each idea
builds on the previous one,
so that by the time
we're done, we've
had a change from this
level of understanding up
to this new level
of understanding.
We now have a new ability.
We know something new.
The pitch.
We start here.
And we've got a
bit of a problem.
And that problem looks kind of
like a big old nasty mountain
or a hurdle in front of us.
And so what we're going to do
is we are going to jump over.
We're going to throw
ourselves over that hurdle,
and we're going to come
down on the other side.
And what we will find is
that-- if we've done it well--
we had to jump pretty
high, but we've still,
even at the end after
we've come down,
we're still at a higher
position than we were to start.
That's a pitch.
And the last one is the big one.
This is called the drama,
where we start here,
and everything is
just going along fine.
And then all of a sudden,
the stuff hits the fan,
and life starts to get bad,
and things get really bad.
And then they get worse
and worse and worse
until we're down here
in this pit of despair.
It's all over.
But no, we find a
way to come back.
We start to work
our way back up.
We figure out how to do it.
We save ourselves.
And we come back
with so much power
that we actually burst
way past our starting line
with this entirely
new lesson that we've
learned because we
had to struggle.
Every story, every presentation,
whatever we're going to give
is going to be based on one
of those four storylines.
Now, how would we
pick which storyline
would be the best one for us
to use for our presentation?
Well, there they are again.
We might want to think about,
are we delivering information?
If just information is enough,
then perhaps a report's enough.
Do we want to deliver ability?
Do we want to help people
have a new ability?
We will use the explanation.
Do we want to help people
get across a hurdle,
solve a problem in a new way?
Then we'd want to do a pitch.
And do we want to have people
go through some suffering
so that on the other
side they can increase
their level of
happiness with us?
Then we're going to
want to give the drama.
A little bit earlier, I said
any extraordinary presentation
changes people.
Well, there are only four
ways that people change.
We change our information.
We know these things.
Perhaps tomorrow, we're going
to know these new things.
OK?
We've changed our information.
We can change our knowledge.
What do we know?
We may think this today.
And tomorrow, perhaps
we'll know some new thing.
We've changed our knowledge.
We may change our action.
Perhaps today, we're
just standing still.
And tomorrow, we will be
running very, very fast.
So we can change our action.
Or the big one, of course, again
is we can change our beliefs.
Perhaps today, we
are cat people.
And maybe tomorrow, we are
going to be dog people.
Ooh, wouldn't that be a change?
Those are the only four
ways that people change.
There's really not a
whole lot more than that.
So here's the cool thing
about those four storylines.
This is kind of the magic.
If we know what kind of a change
we would like our audience
to experience through
our presentation,
we know which storyline to use.
It's as simple as that.
If we know what
kind of change we
would like to have take place
during the presentation,
we know what storyline to use.
Like this.
If I simply want to
change your information,
I want to give you new facts,
I'm going to give you a report.
If I want to change or
knowledge and your ability--
if you can do this
today, but we want
you to be able to
do that tomorrow--
I'm going to give
you an explanation.
If I want you to
change your actions--
we are moving this
way today, but we
need to move that way-- I am
going to give you a pitch.
If we are going to
change our beliefs--
we believe this
to be true, but I
want you to believe
that to be true--
the only way I can do that
is by giving you a drama.
If I know which change I want
to have the audience experience,
I know which storyline
I want to pick.
Today, I want to focus on
just one of these storylines.
It's the drama, because
this is really the big one.
This is the one-- because
this changes beliefs,
this is the one that
has the most power ever.
And so I wanted to
spend time on this one.
Yes, I'm guessing
that most of the time
when at Google, you need
to give a presentation.
You will be needing
to give reports,
because you have a bunch of
facts you need to deliver.
I would encourage all of you
to never give a report again.
I don't care what your
lead is asking for.
Never give them a report.
Nobody ever got a
raise, nobody ever
got a promotion for giving
a really great report.
What you will want to do is use
one of the other storylines.
And you will couch
the facts within that,
but that is the
storyline that people
are going to find compelling.
So, in a way, I would like
to encourage you from now on,
anytime you need to give
a report, to maybe start
to think about some of the
elements that take place
in the storyline we're going
to explore now, the drama.
If there was a patron
saint of presenters,
it would be this
guy, Joseph Campbell.
Now, I know many of you
know who Joseph Campbell is.
Is there anybody in here who is
familiar with Joseph Campbell?
Has anybody heard
of Joseph Campbell?
So Joseph Campbell
was a historian.
And he started working
in the late 1920s,
and he worked all the way
up through, I believe,
the early 1980s.
And what Joseph Campbell did
is he traveled the world.
He was fascinated
by the great myths
of all of the great cultures
through all of history
around the world.
And he did is he went out
and he traveled around.
And he learned to speak
seven different languages.
He traveled all over the world.
And he would get to
know the great myths
from each one of the cultures.
And what was really
fascinating is
he started to realize that there
were a lot of common threads
that existed between all
of these great myths in all
of these different
languages from all
cultures around the world.
And one of the things
that Joseph Campbell did
is he wrote a book called "The
Hero with a Thousand Faces."
And what it was was
it's a big thick tome.
It's his summary
of the commonality
that he found between all
of these great world myths.
And one of pieces
that was in that book
is something that became
known as the hero's journey.
And when Joseph Campbell
introduced this back
in the 1950s, it didn't
really go anywhere.
Nobody but a few
academics thought
this was particularly
interesting.
But since that time, for
reasons we will explore,
this has become a really,
really common thread
for how do we come up
with an interesting story.
This is Joseph
Campbell's own drawing.
He drew a little circle to
describe the hero's journey.
And he drew the circle
moving in this direction,
moving counterclockwise,
and it goes like this.
We start at point X, at
which a hero, who's usually
just a common person, crosses
from the regular world, which
is above this line, into a
strange supernatural world,
which is everything
below the line.
In that supernatural
strange world at point Y,
that hero encounters
fabulous forces.
And the hero has to fight
an incredible battle
to vanquish the foe to destroy
those forces in that very
strange world.
And then, having
learned the lessons
of having fought that battle,
the hero then, at point Z,
comes back into
the regular world
but now a very changed person.
Because of the heroic acts,
because of the battles
that that person had to fight
in the strange world, when they
come back to the
regular world, they now
have this extra
amazing knowledge
that allows that person to
share new insights with people
in the regular world.
Now, that was the way
that he described it.
I think there's a simpler way
that we all know the same idea.
It says this.
Whatever doesn't kill
us makes us stronger.
This is really the
central message
of the whole hero's journey.
Now, the hero's journey has
become kind of something that's
entered into pop
psychology, and it's
getting kind of beaten
to death and all of that.
But a lot of people
say, no, no, no, there's
no such thing as hero's journey.
Well, let's check and see
if Joseph Campbell might
have been right.
And the way I thought
that it would make sense
to check to see if
this story, this drama,
actually has power
for us is to look
at what's popular to look at--
the three most successful movie
franchises in history
around the world.
If there's any way
to say, is there
something that resonates
for people in general
about this story?
Well, let's see if this story
carries through the three most
successful popular stories
pretty much of all time.
So we're going to
look at three of them.
One which takes place in the
past, a mythical past, which
will be of course "The
Lord of the Rings."
One of these stories takes
place in a mythical present,
which is "Harry Potter."
And one of these stories
which takes place
in a mythical future,
which is "Star Wars."
And yes, I know.
I know it begins by
saying, "A long time ago,"
but let's face it.
I mean, it's interstellar
travel and it's spaceships.
It's the future.
So yes.
So-- well, you bring
up an excellent point.
Let's see if this plays out.
So let's look at
these three stories
and see if they
all tell something
that looks like the same story
and some kind of a story that
might adhere to
this hero's journey.
So all of these stories
involve the hero
who is always this
unassuming guy who
is cast into a new world
against his own desire.
He just wants to continue
living this happy life,
but something gets
in front of them
and forces him to
go into a new world.
And this story that this
hero is going to experience
is that he's going
to save the world.
And in the case of
Frodo, he's going
to start here in
the happy Shire,
and then things are
going to get really bad,
and then he's going to
pop out on the other side.
In the case of Harry,
he's going to start out
in the regular world, and things
are going to get really bad.
Then he's going to pop
out on the other side.
And in the case of
Luke, he's going
to start out in this plain
planet that nobody cares,
and things are going
to get really bad,
and he's going to pop
out on the other side.
Interesting.
They're all telling
the same story,
and they're all telling it in
almost exactly the same way.
But one of the
things that's also
interesting about
this hero's journey
is that the hero is not alone.
There are other characters that
are helping on this journey.
And what's amazing is these
other characters always
play the same role.
What do I mean?
There is always the
sidekick, the goofy character
who's there to enable the
hero in amazing ways, that's
a kind soul who stays with the
hero through thick and thin.
So it's Sam with Frodo,
and it's Ron with Harry,
and it's Han Solo with Luke.
And then, as we're getting
near the end, they have a fight
and the sidekick leaves.
But the sidekick
always comes back
at the very last moment,
at the last moment,
and is the one who
enables the hero
to finally win, who does the
amazing thing at the end;
whether it's Sam carrying Frodo
and throwing the ring in there,
or whether it's Ron saving
Harry in the last battle,
or whether it's Han Solo flying
in with the Millennium Falcon
at the last second when when
Luke's flying down the death
trench and blows up
the Darth Vader ship.
So there's that character.
But are there more parallels?
Yes, because there always has
to be the mentor, who obviously
it pays to be someone
with a big beard.
So in the case of "The
Lord of the Rings,"
we have Gandalf,
who comes along.
And we've got Dumbledore
in "Harry Potter."
And we've got Obi
Wan in "Star Wars."
And it's interesting,
because remember
what happens in
the hero's journey.
The hero is in a strange
world, a place where
they don't know what's going on.
The job of the mentor is
to guide them and give them
rules of how the world
works in this strange place.
So this ancient wizard who knows
the world provides these clues
and provides information
for how to live
in this strange world and then
dies, leaving the hero alone;
but always, again, comes back
to the hero in spiritual form
at the last possible moment
just before the final climax
and gives them the
last bit of support
that they're going
to need to happen.
And then there is the
princess, because we'll
notice that so far it's
just been a bunch of dudes.
So there are the women
in this hero's journey?
Well, in the classic
hero's journey,
as it is represented
by Joseph Campbell
and clearly by these
three most popular movie
franchises in history,
the woman's role
is kind of interesting
and kind of weird,
because there's always this
woman who is a princess.
And she has some knowledge.
She kind of has the
keys to what it's really
going to take to win
this thing, whether it's
the princess of the elves or
the princess of the muggles
or the princess of the universe.
And she's always a
potential love interest
and always turns out to
be the hero's sister.
For those of you that are
interested in, is there
an aspect of the
hero's journey that
might be more interesting or
appealing from the woman's
perspective, Joseph Campbell
didn't write anything about it.
But there are a
lot of people now.
In fact, there's a woman
whose name is slipping my mind
right now-- I met her
recently-- at Stanford who's
looking to see, is there are
a parallel hero's journey
that might apply from
the woman's perspective?
The theory being as follows.
These stories, these great
myths that have stayed with us,
tended to be the stories that
stayed with us, because they
were the stories
that got retold.
So perhaps what
was happening is it
was the guys who are
retelling the story,
so their stories
continue to get told.
The stories that the
women were retelling
were never getting retold.
But is there a woman's
hero's journey?
And there are people
looking into it.
And it appears
that there may be.
And it's not exactly
the same as the one
we're going through now.
But let's look at this one.
So are there any other
characters that are the same?
And as I was doing
this, I was having fun
taking these stories I know
and getting my little Lego
characters and lining
them up and saying,
why are they all the same?
And it's amazing, because as you
continue through, yes, there's
always this gentle giant.
So whether it's Gimli
or Hagrid or Chewbacca,
again, it pays to have a
really, really big beard
and to be really hairy.
And the idea is you're
always a giant, which
means that initially this
person is very, very scary.
But then the hero realizes
that really the giant
just represents someone with
an enormous heart, someone
with enormous belief who
never wavers in their belief
and continues to provide the
hero with guidance back to,
what do you really
believe in your heart?
And then there's
always the comedy duo.
There are always
these bumbling twins,
and they're always twins
who are screwing everything
up along the way.
They're comic relief.
But they're there for a
reason, because whether it's
merry and pippin,
or Fred and George,
or R2-D2 and C-3PO stumbling
along, telling these jokes,
giving us comic
relief, in the end,
they all we find in
themselves some aspect
of the heroic journey that
the hero experienced as well.
And they always,
these bumbling fools,
surprise themselves
at the end by what
they are able to accomplish in
spite of their own goofiness.
Now, there would be no story
if there were no bad guy.
So there has to be a bad guy.
And obviously, it pays
if you're a bad guy,
you wear a black cape.
That's how people know
that you're the bad guy,
whether you're Sauron or
whether you're Voldemort
or whether you're Vader.
And also, you are not human.
You do not have a human face.
You are always masked or
you're so horribly disfigured
that you don't look
like a human anymore.
And that's how we know
that you are the villain.
And you are the person
that the hero must defeat.
But the bad guy, the villain,
is not there on their own,
because they always
have an army.
And this is an army
that is always there
in countless number,
unbeatable number,
and, again, is always
masked and always inhuman,
whether it's the Orcs or
whether it's Dementors
or whether it's
the stormtroopers.
And when we first
meet this army,
we know that they
are unbeatable,
because there are so many of
them and they are in human.
But then an amazing
thing happens.
The moment that you kill the
boss, the entire army-- poof--
just disappears.
They all just drop dead right
there, all million of them.
And it turns out that that army
had no strength other than what
came to them from their leader.
The moment you get
rid of the leader,
the army's completely gone
and the battle is over.
So why do I take this time
to share this with you?
Because people pooh-pooh
the hero's journey.
But, oh no, it is
absolutely right.
It's almost as if this is
something that is in us.
This is what a story, this is
what a drama is really about.
And again, if you
just look at movies,
you look at pop culture,
almost all of the big movies
just tell the same story
over and over again.
We change the characters.
We change the time.
Recently, we changed the gender.
But we're always
telling the same story
of this person who
doesn't want to be
in this strange
world, who goes in,
changes, and comes back out.
All right.
So that's kind of cool.
But what about in real life?
I mean, does anything about this
ever take place in the world
that we're in?
Absolutely.
Let's think about
this for a moment.
Do we ever see anything that
happens like this at work?
So this is, again, our line of
the full hero's journey story.
This is really our view
of the whole drama.
And what happens is we start
today where everything's fine.
Some bad trigger happens.
We go into this
point of descent.
We reach this pit of doom
where everything is over.
And this is, by the
way, is known as death.
There is nothing
that's worse than this.
Life is over.
But then we decide, no,
we're not going to die today.
We figure out or we remember or
we find something that tells us
how to begin to get
out of this pit.
And we began to work
our way back up.
And as we work our
way out of that pit,
fighting dragons
along the way, we
start to get so much energy
that, again, we learn a lesson
and we come back
on the other side,
having learned this
entirely new thing.
But does this ever
really happen?
Does it ever happen
that there is someone
who's having a fine
life, and then the life
takes a turn for the worst.
And then that someone
becomes very sad,
because that life is really,
really bad and is just about
on the verge to give up.
Has this ever happened?
And then that person says,
no, I'm not going to give up.
I'm going to find
something that's
going to help me
turn this around.
I'm not going to die today.
And then that person,
just through the act
of deciding to try to improve,
finds that things get better,
and then it comes screaming
out on the other side.
This happens all the time.
And this happens in
business all the time.
This is the way we tell
stories about what we do,
about business.
Think about some of our great
business or pop culture heroes.
One of the reasons that
we love these stories
is because they tell
the same story again.
Lady Gaga--
disastrous childhood,
drug addiction, homeless,
saved by her grandmother,
and becomes Lady Gaga.
We have Howard
Schultz at Starbucks.
So Howard Schultz is CEO of
Starbucks, leaves Starbucks,
Starbucks starts to stumble.
This is about four
or five years ago.
You remember there was this day?
Howard Schultz is
reined back in.
They said, we need you, man.
We need you back.
You've got to be CEO.
He steps back in.
First thing he does?
He looks over the whole thing.
You remember this?
Four years ago, for one
day, every Starbucks
around the world was shut down.
He said, forget it.
You can't your latte today.
I'm closing them down.
We're doing a
global reset that's
as bottom as you can
get, and now we're
coming back up on
the other side.
Or whether it's Richard Parsons,
who managed to weather and save
Time Warner during this
disastrous AOL merger
and ended up becoming CEO of
Time Warner, because he was
the one who was able to save it.
And then the best of all,
back to Harry Potter,
if there's anybody who
has a legitimate right
to write the hero's journey
again, it's JK Rowling.
Her story?
Single mother on
welfare, disastrous life,
writing away this
little book in the cafe
in this little town in the
UK, working on it day in
and day out and finally
getting that book published
and going on to become
the most successful author
of the last three decades.
This is the story that we love.
So what I would
like to encourage
you to think about-- it
might seem a bit abstract.
You will be asked
by the person who's
responsible for your
quarterly review
to come in and give a report
about what you've been doing.
That would be lovely to
give them just the facts.
But wouldn't it be
amazing if you could also
deliver some of those facts
in the form of a story that
is this powerfully compelling?
I guarantee if you do
that, your mentor is
going to look at
you a little bit
differently and perhaps give
you maybe even a little bit
more support on
what you need to do.
Just a little bit of magic to
think about for the next time
you want to give a
presentation on anything.
Whether you're
giving the report,
whether you're giving
the explanation,
the pitch, if you
can add in a little
bit of the drama,
it will be that much more
extraordinary, which brings us
back to rule number three,
tell the story with pictures.
So 35 minutes ago, I shared
with you 30 random pictures.
I'm going to show you
those pictures again now.
Now, I'm going to
show you two pictures.
I would like you tell
me, right or left,
which is the one we saw before.
Which when did we see before?
AUDIENCE: Left.
Right.
Left.
DAN ROAM: That's
why we use pictures.
100%.
Our memories are
stored as images.
They are stored as pictures.
It's very rare that our
memories are stored as words.
When we memorize words,
what we tend to do
is just remember the words
but not what they mean.
Images are the way that
we really, really remember
and convey our messages, so I
encourage you to use pictures.
So if we just do those things,
truth and story and pictures,
public speaking does not
need to be hard at all.
In fact, it can be a
tremendous amount of fun.
And if you like that,
there's more in that book,
"Show and Tell."
I encourage you to take a look.
And if you like that, I
have something online called
the Napkin Academy, where a lot
of the things that I talk about
are available as videos,
all stored in YouTube.
So again, I want to thank
you so much for your time,
for letting me share a little
bit about truth, story,
and pictures.
It's always my pleasure
to talk at Google.
Thank you so much.